but there was like a dude who got eaten
here no that's what we got me a happy
issues you sure how to protect you
perfectly fine can we have Shark Week
for the rest of our lives ESA yes cuz we
need hey guys welcome to behind the
scenes of Shark Week we were packed and
ready to go we've got all of the
necessary goodies we're off to get some
fake blood and some bandages because
we're gonna need it it's chalk we it's
Shark Week moaning oh I'll just let you
put your clothes on hey help you're a
professional oh my god I think I would
be claustrophobic in them wait you're
suited up uh about to shoot our first
actually we did we shot the first name
maven yeah first one is already done
yeah it was uh me zipping myself up
whatever happens don't stop filming okay
Oh get somebody else to get somebody
else to say emergency is not sharks not
an emergency
we're okay get somebody over I need
someone else just film and less like
you're the only person that can save us
ah half of this to heels right okay yeah
good cool all right second scene on my
board is this string make me not cool
really
everyone has a string really really
cycle that off no you want to cut it off
that's how you take it
you take the white sea dog
what like you look great it's like wait
are you skateboarding are you going
surfing like you're confused I got some
swings too much okay give me going
towards your I'm gonna walk with you
let's go this way get on your board and
go for it yeah just so we shot up our
second or third man you're a little
skateboarding gonna maybe a little
computers whoo this is not surfboard but
it's okay we're about to get in the
water now
will this save me in case of emergency
never now man who starts might be afraid
of polka-dots
all right great game
my name's nothing
welcome sexier
I can pull up here
filming Nathan taking off the booties
see what you do ha ha well I got bit by
a shark a little bit of an accident
there's also a wedding proposal going on
no problem no get in my actually I think
you get more chant if it's not sunny
sometimes ya don't realize blood that's
Lily right
what's that that's the people ad that
was a movie I'm just making things up
now
okay that's good for the fifth right
okay
weights will be sand yep the sucks for
Nala here
okay that's great good
Oh
before blood
your arms Oh
you guys thought you
it's a great video house you seen tries
to get to a shark suit fails suffocates
well let's rap on Shark Week 2014 thank
you guys for watching
ah I'm dirty I am dirty so if you
haven't watched the actual music video
go check it out ah that's all I have to
say that's it okay bye gonna hit anyone
sign on back right on please
I wasn't it looking good man do you see
anyone uh well she will sit in there hmm
real close real close it's okay it's
okay I've got a backup camera
I got him sweating and dirty oh my god
it will go away and you can't do
anything like time no sorry
oops oops
never stopped filming oops
oh you're real close over here say be
careful I'm gonna let them go first cuz
I'm illegal mmm what by one way you mean
uh actually only one way
oops it's okay now we're okay
okay
but you stepped on me anyway
it's more than a flash